good evening everyone i'm laura ingraham
and welcome to the first ever ingram
angle town hall now first would like to
thank the city of chicago and our
audience here for hosting us for an
incredibly important discussion Chicago
is one of the truly great American
cities spectacularly beautiful the
summer and winter but in recent years
its gang violence problem has reached
epidemic proportions a level of violence
it's just unacceptable for anywhere in
America the city is on pace for more
than 2000 shootings this year which will
mark the fifth straight year it stopped
that grim mark and just so you get some
perspective since 2011 the year that
Rahm Emanuel took office as mayor there
have been over 4,000 murders in this
city that's more than the 3481 soldiers
who were killed in action in Operation
Iraqi Freedom from 2003 to 2010 if you
can believe it and it's not just the
level of violence in the city that's the
problem it's the lack of justice
according to an analysis conducted by
The Washington Post Chicago police have
made an arrest in only about 27% of
homicides since 2010 that's the lowest
rate of any city the post examined four
non-fatal shootings it's even worse the
University of Chicago Crime Lab tells us
just ten percent of shootings resulted
in an arrest in 2014 and by 2016 the
latest year available that number had
dropped to just five percent the
unsolved crimes undoubtedly fuel a
vicious cycle of distrust between law
enforcement and community and no one is
immune from this violence throughout the
hour we're gonna talk to members of law
enforcement community activists
religious and political leaders as well
as members of the audience to try to
figure out why this tragedy is unfolding
in Chicago and how to stop it let's get
started tonight with Anthony Napolitano
he's a
former police officer and the sole
Republican in Chicago's 50 seat City
Council Martin Priebe who was a member
of Chicago's Fraternal Order of Police
and Kevin Graham president of the
Fraternal Order of Police Chicago Lodge
7 Anthony let's start with you this is
so both heartbreaking and infuriating we
have a world of violence across the
globe heartbreaking stories every day
but as Americans
I can't imagine we find this level of
violence in a city a spectacular of
Chicago with its rich history acceptable
what do we do the biggest problem I
think right now and to see Chicago is
they're not breaking it down into three
different groups what's what's plaguing
our city it's you got an incredible
amount of narcotics that come through
the city of Chicago you got an enormous
amount of guns on the street that just
last year alone I'm sorry in 2018 alone
almost 5,200 guns are been recovered we
have a sale of stolen merchandise a part
of a criminal element on the street that
it's just it's a multi-million dollar
industry so you don't just have
gangbangers going around shooting each
other this is a fight over territory
this is a tight fight over who's making
money on the street right now then if
you can't get to the street and say hey
you got to stop the the narcotics that
are coming in in the in the boatloads
and we have to get more of these guns
off the streets and then we have to
realize that the criminal element is
using the streets to sell the sell
stolen merchandise we're never gonna get
ahead of this for this problem I mean
your number was actually wrong we had
were over the 2000 market people shot in
Chicago ready and we have 375 sites so
we've surpassed the number of people
shot I always say can imagine how many
have been missed Kevin the police have
had their hands full that's for sure the
level of violence but you see the number
of murders solved suspects arrested and
it's a pretty small percentage compared
to other cities as you saw in that in
that analysis why well there's a couple
of reasons the first reason is first of
all we had 2025 shootings in the city
up-to-date yes of today first of all it
started it didn't start yesterday it
served several years ago when they
decided to underfund and under man the
police department we have we are still
almost a thousand policemen short of
where we need to be here a thousand
police officers short in the city of
Chicago today we only have half of the
detectives that we need we used to have
2,000 detectives how many how now just
about a thousand well what's the reason
for that what I mean what are the
politicians say you're gonna have the
mayor rahm emanuel for that bad answer
you know he's the one that closed three
police stations he's the one that calls
to detective areas we didn't do them we
have always at the FOP tried to
interject our solutions to the problem
but when it requires money were shut out
our opinion doesn't count that's part of
the problem and that was what has to
change
we certainly want to go out there and do
the job that we were hired to do but
because they have decided to have more
police oversight they've accepted the
ACLU in their long stop cards because
they have decided that we're going to
work 12-hour days we're not going to
allow people time off they're all wears
on police officers and that is what is
contributed to the problems in this city
let's now go to Melanie Brown who
prefers not to reveal her political
party Melanie welcome thank you for
having me all right so we know that all
police aren't bad you know but when some
of the police officers hurt our
community then we feel like some of the
other police officers should come
together and try to help the community
because they should care about what the
community thinks about the police
department so I just wonder what ever
happened to the good cop bad cop you
know where there's one group of police
officers we might be afraid of but then
there's the good cop where they can
share you know who did the murder what's
the crime or anything like that and we
can get more you know crime solved for
our community and to help everyone going
back to the
you trust yes trust between the
community and law enforcement law
enforcement so to keep people safe when
you call the police you want to have
that level trust and the police want you
to trust them otherwise they're not able
to do their job either Martin as a
writer in the group I would answer that
by pointing to one statistic the the
city of Chicago has paid over 700
million dollars in police misconduct
cases and many many of these cases these
claims against the police are bogus and
they're used to they're used to push
this narrative of police corruption that
is quite often fraudulent and the city
pays out on these and creates this
industry of suing police officers that
in turn lends itself to more police
oversight and even good police officers
and I believe the overwhelming majority
of them are good I think when officers
do something wrong it's generally a
mistake but all officers now in Chicago
face an absolutely ludicrous level of
oversight and and potential lawsuits and
criminal charges by a prosecutor that is
clearly anti police and so this is one
of the reasons that the police are
unable to do the kind of effective
police work that they want to do
policing is an art and the city is now
set up in so many levels some examples
so let's say when you you brandish your
firearm
for any particular reason do you have to
write a report on every time you
brandish about yeah but that's what
they're trying that's what I Rahm
Emanuel on let me go back to one of our
officers they were trying to find that
he had done something wrong
it was the FOP that dug our heels in and
found out that what was going on in
April was they were trying to hold
secret investigations and not divulge
the outcome of those to the officer
which cleared him they were they wanted
to make sure that all officers were
found guilty that's unacceptable I don't
care if it's a citizen said that there's
a secret investigation going on or it's
a police officer people need to be
treated fairly and on four
police officers are not treated fairly
so so you think it's the accusation
against a police officer they're
presumed guilty by the community so
there's a distrust between the community
police police don't trust the accusation
no or no no it is the investigative body
all cases that involve shootings are
sent to the to the federal to the FBI
and to the state's attorney's office for
prosecution I think what we're getting
at and it's painfully obvious when you
have a thousand detective deaths deficit
on a police force it could be a lot of
things is it is it money not allocated
is it the pay is not enough is it
demoralize police is it too dangerous
and people feel like for the risk I'm
taking I'm not getting much of a benefit
you're damned if you do you're damned if
you don't why am I gonna do this job me
police policing should be it is a noble
profession but Anthony it's you here two
police officers they feel like
oftentimes they feel like they can do no
right but we have concerned citizens who
say we need more of a collaboration here
well I've gotta be able to fix this I'd
love to answer that question I was a
police officer myself I worked the
street I worked in the 15 district in
Austin I was a gang enforcement officer
so to answer this young lady's question
I've done that job I built relationships
on the street with other officers and
there was the ability to work crime
based off relationships you have but
what's happened is a culture through
America now as the police are becoming
enemy the neighborhoods are kind of
closing their doors and don't want to
answer the police don't be a snitch
don't be a snitch cuz snitch kids and
snitches get stitches and that's a
concept on the street I've seen that
t-shirt yeah and you know what there's
always this concept that there's this
thin blue line between officers they
don't talk the code of silence that's
not even true the thin blue line is a
certain amount of officers that will
take a bullet for each other and protect
each other the bigger line that's harder
to cross is in the neighborhoods when
nobody wants to talk about what they saw
for many reasons they don't want to get
stitches but it's part of a big element
in the neighborhood they're throughout
the whole city well there's a lot of
money being made on the street so you're
hurting that you're hurt enterprise on
the street alone now let's go to read
well as a Republican with a question
about federal involved
in Chicago reading so my question for
the panelists is whether or not they
support president Trump's previous calls
for the National Guard to be sent here
to Chicago and if so what would the
National Guard be able to do that local
police cannot can't president Trump you
know mentioned the National Guard of
Chicago it's been thrown around before I
certainly I believe that anytime we have
federal agents federal law enforcement
agents they're welcome and certainly I
have nothing against federal troops and
I'm sure that the president meant that
is trying to help the city I think what
we need to do is make sure that
politicians realize that they have to
spend the money to hire police officers
hire the right police officers make sure
they are trained have a facility in
which to train them and then also be out
there in the community we've removed our
foot officers through the most of the
city and we need to put those they're
shutting down detective
detective a detective offices in these
difficult neighbors Englewood and so
forth when I read that that that was
another concern by the police well they
they did they closed they have closed
some some districts and whatnot that
that has been the case but you know I
don't know I really couldn't say about
the National Guard you know to me it's
like this is a local problem and for the
most part it has a local solution I
think it's a bit of a myth though to say
that the that there's complete distrust
in communities between the police
there really isn't there's a still a lot
of people they call us they rely on us
they want us to help them you know a lot
of is the gang so most of the violence
is gang violence and they don't 9:59
major gangs with a lot of offshoots 2400
offshoots of these gangs and and among
the most vicious in the country and in
the world guys all of you thank you so
much for your input tonight